the yellowstone prequel 1883 was full of
painful surprises and slow reveals but
did you know the finale had more
connections to the original series than
meets the eye keep watching for the
truth behind 1883's final moments
with elsa seriously injured from the
wound inflicted by the comanche and
racing clouds james and margaret take
her to the nearby fort to see a surgeon
they suspect the wound is infected due
to the fact it wasn't healing with
joseph and his wife also sick and
injured shea agrees to the detour at the
start of this is not your heaven they
arrive at a small fort guarded by two
teenage soldiers
their call for a surgeon is answered by
major hempel who has no staff and no
nurses after examining elsa the major
reveals that the arrow that struck her
hit her liver and that she's already
gone septic he tells shea and thomas
that there is nothing he can do for elsa
and that what they thought was their
salvation is little more than a meeting
place for ambitious railroad engineers
mapping the region he explains that fort
laramie is their best option and not by
much
she's done traveling
laramie as far as she goes if you're
lucky
best you can hope for is that she wakes
and you get to say goodbye
at this point it seems the hope that
fans had pinned on elsa's survival in
the previous episode were crushed by the
major's sobering words
when they realized that elsa's arrow
wound won't heal james and margaret
clash over what they should tell their
daughter drifting in and out of
consciousness elsa remains steadfast
that she'll recover and her mother
doesn't want to take that hope away
james meanwhile believes in his
daughter's strength and spirit and wants
to be honest with her about the
seriousness of her wound as it becomes
more and more clear that their daughter
won't survive tension between james and
margaret arises it's unspoken but james
is clearly frustrated that he can't tell
elsa the truth and that she may die
without ever being able to say goodbye
margaret meanwhile is still holding on
to the last vestiges of hope that elsa
might recover she even reassures elsa
that her fever has broken and she's
looking better while this decision
upsets james he still agrees to lie to
elsa when she confronts him
when 1883 first started many fans of
yellowstone must have scratched their
heads when they learned james dutton
wasn't traveling to montana but instead
joined a wagon train headed to oregon
audiences knew the train would be
diverted at some point and began
theorizing how and why it would
eventually happen we finally discover
the reason in the finale with the fort
offering little help for elsa and the
next destination too far to reach in
time james and shea decide they must
make drastic changes to their travel
plans if they're to give elsa a proper
resting place the journey that was
destined to end in oregon will now
divert to the bozeman valley in montana
where he tells the group they will spend
the winter before departing for oregon
in the spring with their numbers
dwindling elsa dying and joseph and his
wife unable to travel it seems the best
and only option for survival
unfortunately the rest of the group is
adamant that they continue onto oregon
with or without shea the grizzled war
veteran promises he'll still get them to
oregon but they insist on continuing
despite shea's warnings their minds are
made up we are staying
a trail is easy enough to follow now
we'll make it to oregon without you suit
yourself
yellowstone fans now know why the
duttons settled in montana and it was
due to a tragedy few saw coming when the
series began
as the rest of the wagon train departs
for oregon on their own jay stays behind
with james dutton and his family
preparing to begin their journey to the
bozeman valley shea releases the cattle
and lets cowboys colton and wade depart
the wagon and train after saying goodbye
to their companions they ride off to an
unknown future thomas noemi and their
children decide to stick with shea
joseph and his wife also want to go to
montana but shea refuses them saying
they are too sick to keep up noemi
demands they be allowed to join them
declaring to shay that they are now free
people whether they live or die she even
offers up her own services as driver of
their wagon as days drag on and joseph's
snake bite continues to worsen they're
forced to face the stark truth that he
might not make it to montana thomas then
offers yosef a choice they can amputate
the snake bitten leg or he can die with
it joseph chooses the only real option
and shea and thomas prepare to become
battlefield surgeons getting yosef drunk
enough to pass out they remove joseph's
leg in a brutal surgery by fire light to
which the rapidly dying elsa responds
sure glad i didn't get shot in the leg
before the surgery on yosef shea and
james sit around a fire and talk while
margaret sings elsa a lullaby james
explains that she only sings for their
children and that she paradoxically
promised to sing at his funeral despite
making him promise he'd die after her
however it's shay who tells the most
revealing story of the night he finally
opens up about his past and how his wife
helped him survive the civil war
according to shea his wife back home had
sent him a letter explaining that she
was leaving him for another man
prompting him to leave his unit and
return home with the intent to kill his
wife's new lover when he got there it
turned out to be a ruse designed to get
him to leave the war ultimately saving
him from death on the battlefield at
gettysburg and reuniting the couple it's
a touching story one that gives new
meaning to shae's longing for the family
we saw him leave behind in the premiere
episode the story illustrates the
sadness in shae's past and the passion
that drives him throughout the series it
also helps explain the respect he has
for james and his relationship with his
wife and daughter the love he sees in
their eyes proves that he's more than
just a hardened war veteran
the settler's decision to proceed to
oregon without shea was met with
derision from the cowboy who warned them
they would die if they attempted to go
it alone he insisted that their best
hope for survival was to spend the
winter in the valley and set off for
oregon in the spring but the remaining
group had had enough of brennan's delays
even with his protection he had gotten
many of them killed crossing a river
with more dying due to accidents and
attacks the settlers also felt that at
this point in the journey the trail was
well marked enough that they didn't need
shea as a guide a decision which would
quickly doom them
not long after splitting up a group of
bandits attacked the wagon train looting
it and killing everyone they found it
was another grim reminder of the
lawlessness and brutality of life on the
planes and the dangers that lurk around
every corner they came to american
shores with dreams of freedom and
prosperity but in the end they wound up
meeting their fate at the end of an
outlaws pistol
though all hope seems lost for elsa as
james shea and the remaining members of
the group take her north towards montana
to die they have an unexpected run-in
with a band of friendly native americans
the leader of the tribe an elder named
spotted eagle sees that elsa is in rough
shape and says he has a doctor in his
own group that may be able to help her
what do your
doctors say
you have no doctors
i'll get you a doctor
after days spent injured on the trail
elsa finally gets proper attention for
her wound from two medicine women who
take her to a nearby stream and flush
out the infection audiences may have
believed this was the moment when things
would change for elsa and she might
finally be saved it would have made
thematic sense if she were healed by the
tribe since she had bonded to a native
american man earlier in the season
unfortunately the tribe's prognosis
wasn't any better than the forts the
leader of the tribe explains that the
lakota coat the tips of their arrows in
cow manure to ensure that their victims
are killed by infection if not from the
wound itself despite their medical
attention and a spiritual ceremony it
seems that there was truly no saving the
young elsa
dutton having accepted his daughter's
fate james tells spotted eagle of his
intention to take elsa into the
mountains to die he explains that
wherever elsa lays is where he and his
wife plan to lay claim and build a ranch
he goes on to say he does not know this
region and fears it will not be
hospitable to him in response spotted
eagle suggests a valley he hunted while
growing up the winters are
cruel but the summers are rich in a man
who
plans can thrive
spotted eagle says it is called paradise
valley which yellowstone fans will
recognize as the real life valley where
the series is set it's also the name of
a capital investment firm run by dan
jenkins that tries to push the duttons
off the yellowstone more than a hundred
years later
spotted eagle also gives james a word of
warning telling him that in seven
generations his people will rise up to
reclaim their land the one thing he asks
of james is permission to continue
hunting in the valley which she happily
gives this also explains james kindness
towards a small tribe we saw him meet in
flashbacks in yellowstone as he owes
them a great debt for helping elsa and
pointing them to their new home in the
valley
finally realizing that she won't get
better and will soon die elsa feels
betrayed that her father lied to her
while speaking to her father she
requests to choose the spot where she is
to die james grants her request as
margaret watches from a distance
distraught that her daughter has to face
the truth of her own demise however it's
once again wisdom from shea brennan that
helps james come to terms with elsa's
impending doom the veteran soldier
consoles him with the fact that elsa
lived a full life fuller than most
despite her young age she had outlived
us all
elsa had a happy childhood and a loving
family she traveled the planes rode
horses joined a wagon train saw the
beauty of the land and bonded with many
of its inhabitants she clashed with
comanche and battled bandits
she fell in love more than once and was
loved back elsa had indeed lived the
american dream and death was now the
last destination on a short journey
through this world
in this is not your heaven fans of
yellowstone finally get the significant
connections they've been looking for all
season long we learn what pulled james
dutton off the path to oregon to
founding the yellowstone ranch after
years of hints and references to family
legacy we finally understand the spark
that ignited the dutton's passion for
their home in montana in an early part
of the episode else amuses to her father
that the only thing she fears about
death is being forgotten james and
margaret vowed that if she's to die they
will make their home where they bury her
so they can visit her grave every day
ensuring her memory when elsa chooses a
spot by a tree near where the dutton
ranch is to be built audiences finally
understand the dutton's ancestral claim
to the land we've heard john dutton's
promise to his father not to let the
land go and now we see that the same
promise has been handed down for
generations it seems that dutton's claim
to the yellowstone ranch stretches back
to 1883 with the death of elsa dutton
while her descendant john dutton refuses
to relinquish it it remains to be seen
if spotted eagle's prophecy that his
people will one day reclaim it is true
once elsa passes away in her father's
arms the story flashes forward one year
while we do not see james and margaret
in their new ranch we do get updates on
the surviving cast joseph is seen on
crutches his right leg amputated as he
removes his wedding band in memory of
his wife he pulls a stack of wood planks
from his horse and we're left to believe
that he is building his new home in a
valley he is the lone survivor of his
group but he has finally found the home
he set out to build when the series
began we then cut to willamette valley
oregon and see noemi and thomas staking
a claim on a plot of land near a river
naomi's two children rushed to embrace
her this is especially meaningful
because earlier we learned that her
children blamed her for the death of
their father and hadn't spoken to her
since finally in oregon they build a new
home and new life with thomas
finally we see shea on a beach looking
out over the water he speaks to his late
wife helen admiring the beauty of the
pacific ocean having completed his
journey and seeing nothing left to hang
on to
shea ends his own life while sitting on
the shoreline whether heart warming or
devastating the ending of 1883 won't
leave a dry eye in the house
when the series began audiences may have
suspected that 1883 would be a series
very much like yellowstone a high octane
drama full of action and suspense the
wild west seemed like the perfect place
for the series first spin-off and surely
fans dreamed of rough-riding cowboys
chasing down bandits in a fast-paced
western adventure when it premiered
viewers were instead treated to a somber
and emotional drama a slower more
intimate look at life on the frontier
than they may have expected while james
indeed played a central role it became
clear right away that it would be elsa
dutton's story as she narrated her
journey north from texas an unexpectedly
subdued premiere episode gave way to a
series that provided background to
yellowstone while telling its own story
that required no prior knowledge perhaps
the most surprising thing about 1883 is
that it wasn't the story of hope and
discovery that many may have thought
instead the series was ultimately a
bleak tale of the hopelessness and
sorrow felt by so many as they ventured
out onto the frontier though there are
moments of joy to be found even those
are bittersweet as so many of the series
characters meet untimely ends the
unforgiving narrative we're left with
illustrates how every element of early
american life was fraught with danger
and death
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]